[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
55 lange Stunden haben die Retter aus
Deutschland gekämpft sie waren der
Strohhalm an den sich alle klammerten
und es gelangt ist gerettet sie war
begraben unter den Trümmern eines
Hochhauses im türkischen Erdbebengebiet
es gibt keine Worte um das zu
beschreiben vier Tage nach dem Beben
leben
guten Abend ihnen allen aber leider auch
unendlich viel Tod die Zahl der Opfer
stieg heute im gesamten Erdbebengebiet
auf fast 23.000 die Zerstörung ist
unfassbar man kann dieses Ereignis nicht
einfach als Schicksal abtun sagt auf
einem Video dass in der Türkei gerade
herumgeht ein gewisser recept type
Erdogan das war nach einem Erdbeben 2003
erdogan ist heute Staatspräsident sind
die verheerenden Folgen auch des
aktuellen Bebens nicht einfach Schicksal
auch diese Frage wird lauter zur Trauer
kommt die Wut unsere reporterin Anne
Brühl ist vor Ort
Kuscheltiere und Trümmer wie bloß soll
man das begreifen können
Überleben in escendoronen mitten
zwischen Tod und Zerstörung die Stadt
liegt in der Provinz hartei die
besonders hart getroffen wurde
meine Mutter ist unter den Trümmern
meine Nichte sie versuchen mit den
Baggern sie rauszuholen aber bis jetzt
waren sie nicht erfolgreich Abfahrt hat
gesagt dass es zu risikoreich ist bis
jetzt konnten sie keinen erreichen
das ist die türkische
Katastrophenschutzbehörde schwer
vorstellbar dass sie immer noch
Überlebende aus diesem Trümmern Bergen
wie viele Menschen allein hier gestorben
sind wie viele noch vermisst werden
keiner weiß das
es gibt bei den Rettungsarbeiten immer
noch Menschen die wir lebendig rausholen
aber diese Arbeit werden wir innerhalb
der nächsten Tage beenden
Zahlen Fakten will auch er uns nicht
nennen nur so viel
die größte Katastrophe die wir je
gesehen haben
von den Behörden sind viele mit denen
wir sprechen enttäuscht so wie
nazirkillinaldi auch noch Freunde
vermisst
kam die Hilfe zu spät
Tagen am Abend Lebensmittel sind nicht
wichtig für uns ist wichtig dass unsere
Angehörigen unter den Trümmern gefunden
werden
zusammen mit Freunden aus Istanbul ist
Berit Erdogan gekommen um zu helfen die
staatlichen Rettungsmannschaften
brauchen jede Unterstützung findet sie
ich will den Staat nicht beschuldigen
dieses Erdbeben hat in zehn Provinzen
stattgefunden der Schaden ist groß der
Bereich ist groß es gibt sehr viele
Betroffene so viele Trümmer deswegen
versucht jeder im Moment das Beste zu
machen
Teile der Stadt stehen unter Wasser das
Hafenviertel war auf Sand und
Betonstützen gebaut als die Erde bebte
senkte sich der Boden und drei Meter
wir räumen die Küstenstraße auf
der Hafen der Stadt der viertgrößte in
der Türkei steht immer noch in Flammen
Container mit Gefahrgut waren in Brand
geraten auch das eine Folge des Bebens
kaum einer kann sich vorstellen wie es
weitergehen soll in es kennbaron es wird
Tage und Wochen brauchen bis die letzten
Leichen geborgen sind Monate bis alle
Trümmer beseitigt sind und bei allem
muss auch an die Überlebenden gedacht
werden
was wir brauchen ist Schutz gegen die
Kälte ein Dach über dem Kopf Container
es wird hier sehr kalt der Wind ist sehr
stark die Leute brauchen Toiletten und
Duschen für ihre Grundbedürfnisse
Überleben nach vorne schauen und
gleichzeitig die nicht vergessen die ihn
es kennen der runden ihr Leben verloren
haben
ja apokalyptische Bilder sind das Anne
brüll unsere Reporterin ist jetzt live
bei uns aus Adana guten Abend Anne wir
haben sie auch gerade in deinem Film
schon gesehen vielleicht kannst du uns
mal beschreiben da ist ja manches
wirklich komplett verwüstet direkt
daneben scheint anderes stellen
ja das ist in der Tat so das betrifft
die Region es kennen darum haben wir
gerade gesehen stark verwüstet und Adana
da sind wir gestern reingefahren da
fährt man vorbei an Hochhaussiedlungen
da sieht alles total normal aus
Geschäftsstraßen alle Läden offen die
Menschen sind unterwegs in der Stadt
Kneipen haben geöffnet in Parks gehen
die Menschen spazieren und dann steht
man plötzlich vor einem Trümmerhaufen
wie dem hinter mir das war mal ein 14
stöckiges Hochhaus und das ist in der
Nacht dieses Lebens einfachen sich
zusammen gesagt und man sieht es
vielleicht die Häuser hier herum die
sind stehengeblieben also nur dieses
eine Haus ist an dieser Stelle hier
zusammengesagt das ist ein Haus von elf
das in Adana eingestürzt ist 11 Häuser
in einer Großstadt von 1,8 Millionen
Einwohner
welche Erklärung haben denn die Menschen
dafür
na die Diskussion die jetzt wieder neu
auftaucht das eigentlich eine alte
nämlich die wie das hier alles passieren
kann und wenn man die Menschen fragt
dann sagen sie einem vor allen Dingen
forsch am Bau und Profitgier das nennen
sie als Hauptgrund da werden zum
Beispiel sagen sie schlechte
Baumaterialien verwendet dann aber
machen Sie natürlich auch die Behörden
dafür verantwortlich denn auch hier in
der Türkei gibt es sowas wie eine
staatliche Bauaufsicht das heißt jeder
Neubau wird auch abgenommen von
Ingenieuren und der letzte Punkt der
dann immer genannt wird es Korruption
ganz herzlichen Dank heute Abend auch
wieder live nach Adana
in Syrien trifft das Beben ein
Bürgerkriegsland Machthaber basshaare
alasat ist ins Erdbebengebiet gereist in
den Teil über den er die Kontrolle hat
im anderen den Milizen in Opposition zu
Assad beherrschen werfen die Menschen
ihm vor Hilfe zu blockieren Assad war im
Bürgerkrieg mit 350.000 Toten brutal
gegen die eigene Bevölkerung vorgegangen
all das führt dazu dass wir über das
wirkliche Ausmaß der Katastrophe in
Syrien immer noch nur böse Vorahnungen
haben die uno-schätzt heute das bis zu
5,3 Millionen Menschen dort obdachlos
wurden Hilfe wäre dringend nötig Golly
nähertal beginnt ihren Bericht im
Nordwesten von Syrien
auf der Straße nach A
fri Erdbeben opf
er syndrand gestrandet nur ein paar
Decken haben sie noch vielleicht hoffen
sie hält jemand an gibt ihnen etwas zu
essen ein bisschen Wärme oder irgendein
Obdach
Samia musste wie alle hier ihr Haus
verlassen sie sagt es hätte jeden Moment
einstürzen können
[Musik]
vier Male wurden wir in den letzten
Jahren vertrieben wir sind so erschöpft
alles was ich jetzt noch will ist ein
Zelt für meine Familie wir hatten eine
Arbeit aber jetzt können wir nichts mehr
tun nichts
im schifffahrt-krankenhaus in etlib
hören die Einsätze nicht mehr auf
Medizinstudenten wurden einberufen aber
das Personal reicht nicht die Medizin
reicht nicht es fehlen Geräte
3000 Kilometer entfernt beobachtet
Gerhard Trabert das Geschehen der
Mainzer Arzt hilft seit Jahren in
Nordsyrien sein Freund vor Ort in etlib
operiere dort ununterbrochen sagt er
Mensch wird es an seiner Stimme wie
erschöpft er ist körperlich und selig
und das kann ich
nachempfinden und fühle mich da häufig
sehr hilflos ihm gegenüber
leider hat bis jetzt nichts dieses
Gebiet erreicht erzählt habe als
arztkollege nichts kein Essen keine
Experten keine Suchtrupps und keinem
einzigen Land leider Lügen alle sorry
an der syrisch-türkischen Grenze sollen
es heute immerhin 29 Lkw nach Nordwest
Syrien geschafft haben aber selbst
innerhalb Nord Syriens kommt keine Hilfe
aus dem Osten in den Westen das Gebiet
ist zersplittert in rivalisierende
Gruppen Kurden pro türkische Milizen
islamistische Rebellen LKW volle
hilfsgüter-
hallo hallo Gerhard Rabatt hat seinen
Kollegen was Ravi Ali erreicht der
Orthopäde arbeitet für trabitz Verein in
kubane Nordsyrien und will im ein paar
Kilometer entfernten Katastrophengebiet
helfen du versuchst dorthin zu kommen
aber das funktioniert leider auch noch
nicht das ist unmöglich und
wir haben keine Chance
sind geschlossen meine Forderung ist
jetzt an die Bundesregierung an die EU
auf den Nato-Partner Türkei massiv Druck
auszuüben dass die Grenze geöffnet
werden muss und natürlich auch noch die
Forderung anders ersatzregime ebenfalls
die Grenzen zu öffnen
auf der Straße nach afrin wenn keine
Hilfe kommt dann ist die zweite
Katastrophe sicher sagen Mediziner dann
sei es zweite sterben geradezu
vorprogrammiert
und auch heute an dieser Stelle der
Hinweis für Sie wenn Sie spenden wollen
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hat
folgendes Konto
de65-100
400-100 400 600 das Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien und Informationen
auch unter Spenden zdf.de oder im ZDF
Text auf Seite 890 und so viel für den
Moment zum verheerenden Erdbeben
dass das Thema auf die Tagesordnung muss
war allen klar in Brüssel die Zahlen
sind zu deutlich im letzten Jahr sind
die Asylanträge in Europa umfasst 50
Prozent gestiegen dazu kommen etwa vier
Millionen geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
und es kommen immer mehr Hilferufe aus
Städten und Gemeinden auch hier in
Deutschland die nicht mehr wissen wie
weiter im Grunde hat die EU bereits
klare Regeln an die sich in den
Mitgliedsstaaten aber kaum jemand hält
seit vergangener Nacht hat die EU jetzt
auch einen Gipfelbeschluss sie will sich
in Zukunft stärker abschotten das Wort
um das sich alles dreht heißt
Infrastruktur an den Grenzen es ist auch
deshalb so europäisch weil jeder selbst
entscheiden kann was das genau bedeutet
Florian neuhahn berichtet
als ein gewisser Donald Trump mit der
Forderung nach einer Mauer zu Mexiko die
Massen mobilisiert
darunter viele in Europa noch die Stirn
als an diesem Morgen um kurz nach halb
vier die letzten den EU-Gipfel verlassen
da ist Europa nach Ansicht mancher auf
dem besten Weg genau dorthin Mauern
Zäune hochzuziehen Österreichs Kanzler
etwa jubelt
asylbremse tatsächlich europaweit
angezogen worden ist in dieser Klarheit
hat es das noch bei keinem Rad gegeben
und das ist jetzt ein wichtiges Signal
wie will Europa seine Grenzen Schützen
mit Zäunen wie hier zwischen Bulgarien
und der Türkei seit 2014 haben Europas
Staaten zwar aufgerüstet von 315 auf
über 2000 Kilometer Zaun aber nur ein
Bruchteil der EU Außengrenze sieht
bisher so aus und vor allem das ist den
Gegnern wichtig floss bisher kein
EU-Geld in solche Zäune eine Mama hat
noch nie eine Lösung gehabt ich glaube
es gibt ja irgendeine zwischen Mexiko
und Amerika hat ja auch nichts
mitgebracht wäre eine Schande wenn eine
Mauer in Europa gebaut wurde mit
den europäischen Sternen drauf doch die
Stimmung hat sich gedreht in diesem
Kreis überall steigen Flüchtlingszahlen
genau wie Wahlergebnisse rechter
Parteien und so üben sie sich in ihrem
gipfelpapier im klassisch europäischer
Wortakrobatik unverzüglich heißt es dort
soll es EU-Geld geben für den Ausbau von
grenzschutzkapazitäten und Infrastruktur
also alles Hauptsache kein Zaun
ist das ein bisschen plakativ das von
ihnen Verwandte Wort ist und keinem der
Texte die wir beschlossen haben
überhaupt aufgetaucht aber natürlich
geht es schon darum dass auch in einen
ganzen
Sicherungsmaßnahmen ergriffen werden
soll heißen Autos Kameras Wachtürme an
den Grenzen erstmals finanziert mit
EU-Geld ein weiterer kleiner Schritt in
Richtung Abschottung den Befürworter
etwa die neue Rechte italienische
Premierministerin Georgia Meloni bereits
als riesige Kehrtwende verkaufen
der Ansatz hat sich geändert der neue
Ansatz unterscheidet sich sehr von dem
den wir in den letzten Jahren auf
EU-Gipfeln gesehen haben
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch das
Europas größte streithema die Verteilung
von geflüchteten auf diesem Gipfel gar
nicht erst angepackt wurde die Arbeit
daran so heißt es wolle man fortsetzen
weitere wichtige Nachrichten vor diesem
Freitag hast jetzt du Hanna die
US-Luftwaffe hat nach Angaben des
Pentagons ein unbekanntes Flugobjekt im
amerikanischen Luftraum abgeschossen es
habe sich vor der Küste Alaskas befunden
und eine Gefahr für die Sicherheit der
zivilen Luftfahrt dargestellt die
Herkunft des Objekts sei unklar das habe
die Größe eines Autos gehabt sei aber
kleiner gewesen als der zuletzt
abgeschossene chinesische
überwachungsballon da sagte der Sprecher
des nationalen Sicherheitsrates
nach Israel dort ist im Osten Jerusalems
ein palästinensischer Mann mit einem
Auto in eine Gruppe von Menschen an
einer Bushaltestelle Gefahren dabei
starben ein sechsjähriges Kind und ein
20-jähriger Mann mindestens fünf
Personen wurden verletzt die Polizei
erklärte der Attentäter sei erschossen
worden der Konflikt zwischen Israelis
und Palästinensern hat sich zuletzt
weiter verschärft
der Bundestag hat ein Gesetz zur
Beschleunigung von großen
Infrastrukturprojekten beschlossen der
Bau von Windkraftanlagen Bahnstrecken
oder Straßen hat künftig Vorrang bei
Gericht der Bundesregierung könne so die
Verfahrensdauer bei wichtigen Projekten
reduziert werden ziel ist unter anderem
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien bis
2030 zu beschleunigen die Union
bezweifelt die Wirksamkeit des Gesetzes
und kritisierte manche Regelungen als zu
Waage
unterdessen haben die unionsgeführten
Länder im Bundesrat ein Gesetzesvorhaben
gestoppt das sogenannte Whistleblower
Gesetz es sollte Personen die auf
Missstände in Firmen oder Behörden
Hinweisen besser schützen unter anderem
durch interne und externe Meldestellen
die Union kritisierte den hohen
bürokratischen Aufwand und die
finanzielle Belastung für Unternehmen
der Bundestag hatte den Gesetzentwurf im
Dezember beschlossen um so eine
EU-Richtlinie umzusetzen ein Kompromiss
könnte nun im Vermittlungsausschuss von
Bundestag und Bundesrat gesucht werden
moldaus pro europäische
Ministerpräsidentin gabrielitza ist nach
nur eineinhalb Jahren überraschend von
ihrem Amt zurückgetreten als Begründung
nannte sie einen Mangel an Vertrauen und
Unterstützung im Land neuer
Regierungschef wird der bisherige
Innenminister richan auch er gilt als
pro europäisch eingestellt seit dem
russischen Angriffskrieg wächst der
Druck auf den grenzstaat der in der
Energieversorgung stark abhängig von
Russland ist
die Offensive der russischen Armee im
Osten der Ukraine war erwartet worden
sie war befürchtet worden es sieht so
aus als habe sie begonnen das Ziel den
gesamten don-bass erobern unter
russische Kontrolle bringen westliche
militärforscher sagen russland habe die
Initiative zurückgewonnen und
mittlerweile große Teile von mindestens
drei großen Divisionen im Einsatz heute
waren die Menschen an vielen Orten in
der Ukraine wieder massiv unter Beschuss
Ulrike rötler hat mehr dazu
17 Angriffe in einer Stunde haben sie
hier in der Nähe von saporizia gezählt
so viel wie noch nie seit Beginn des
Krieges Ziel der russischen Raketen und
Drohnen war das Stromnetz doch die
Geschosse zerstören auch Häuser von
Zivilisten
das sind keine Menschen so würde ich es
ausdrücken ich weiß nicht was die Russen
denken wenn sie so etwas machen wenn Sie
den Knopf drücken und Zivilisten
angreifen es ist schrecklich
aufgrund der massiven Angriffe wurde
heute fast überall in der Ukraine der
Strom abgeschaltet betroffen war auch
die Hauptstadt Kiel hier soll es am
Morgen mehrere Explosionen gegeben haben
viele Bewohner suchen deshalb Schutz in
den Metrostationen 10 russische Raketen
sollen laut ukrainischer Armee über Kiew
abgeschossen worden sein
erst hörte ich eine Explosion dann ging
der Alarm los ungefähr um 10 Uhr morgens
ich hörte eine Rakete und noch eine
Explosion nach 30 Sekunden zerbrachen
die Scheiben wir rannten ins Badezimmer
um uns zu verstecken
die Ukrainer versuchen die Angriffe der
russischen Armee abzuwehren wie hier im
Osten in bachmut oder in herkiff seit
einigen Tagen ist immer wieder die Rede
von einer russischen Großoffensive
Frühjahrsoffensive die ist jetzt im Gang
die wird wahrscheinlich noch stärker
über die nächsten Wochen und Monate weil
einfach schrittweise
mobilgemachte Kräfte die bis jetzt in
Russland trainiert haben ausgebildet
wurden jetzt an die Front kommen und die
wird bis in sozusagen ihren
wahrscheinlich ihren Kulminationspunkt
im Frühling haben mindestens 70 Raketen
an einem Tag so die Bilanz heute noch
sei die ukrainische Verteidigung robust
sagen Beobachter doch Russland wird
Schritt für Schritt den Druck auf die
Ukraine erhöhen
da gehen wir jetzt live nach Kiew zu
Kathrin Eigendorf guten Abend Katrin
wenn das jetzt die Frühjahrsoffensive
der Russen ist wie ja viele Beobachter
sagen was noch muss denn die Ukraine
befürchten
ja guten Abend Christian also die
Ukraine befürchtet das Russland diesen
Krieg weiter eskaliert und zwar auf zwei
Ebenen wir sehen einmal die Situation im
Osten der Ukraine wo es wirklich so ist
dass trotz trotz der Tatsache dass die
Ukraine dort massiv man Militär
zusammengezogen hat Russland immer
weiter die Kontrolle über bachmut
gewinnt und möglicherweise davor ist
dort ein Durchbruch zu erzielen das
heißt sich weiter im in der Region dann
jetzt dort Kontrolle verschafft und auf
der anderen Seite haben wir im gesamten
Gebiet der Ukraine heute Luftangriffe in
einem Ausmaß erlebt wie wir das schon
lange nicht mehr gesehen haben zum Glück
ist es den Ukrainern gelungen viele
Raketenangriffe abzuwehren aber zum
Beispiel eine Stadt wie safariji oder
auch die zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine
Harke selbst hier in Kiew hat es
verstärkte Angriffe gegeben das bedeutet
dass man sich hier in den nächsten
Wochen darauf einstellen muss das weiter
kritische Infrastruktur getroffen werden
kann und dass damit eben auch Probleme
für die Wirtschaft entstehen dass hier
weiter eben Wärmekraftwerke
Stromkraftwerke lahmgelegt werden und
das ganze zeigt eben die ganze Situation
zeigt eben das westliche Waffen zu spät
kommen also das sieht man eben vor allem
im Osten der Ukraine um diese vormärsche
der Russen abzuwehren also darauf
richtet sich die Ukraine auf ein dass
sie sicherlich bis sagen wir mal April
heißt es hier noch mit diesen
verstärkten Angriffen rechnen muss bis
eben dann endlich entsprechende Waffen
Nachschub hier kommt um vielleicht das
Rad noch einmal zu drehen Kathrin
lenkendorf live vielen Dank
die Schweizer führten ihren letzten
Krieg vor 175 Jahren im eigenen Land er
dauerte nicht mal vier Wochen die
Schweiz ist neutral und das ist den
Schweizern auch enorm wichtig
gleichzeitig gehört die Schweiz zu den
15 größten
rüstungsexporteuren der Welt mit Waffen
lässt sich dort also durchaus Geld
verdienen aber die Freigabe von Waffen
an die Ukraine lehnt die Schweizer
Regierung regelmäßig ab heute gab es ein
Berner nein an Spanien das aus der
Schweiz stammende Flugabwehr Kanonen an
die Ukraine geben wollte auch
Deutschland hatte sich ja eine Abfuhr
geholt was besonders deshalb ins Gewicht
fällt weil für gigantische Reserven an
Munition das Okay der Schweiz nötig
gewesen wäre
was wiegt schwerer Schweizer Neutralität
oder internationales Recht Eva Scheller
dass sich die Türen dieser Schweizer
panzerschmiede für Kameras öffnen zeigt
wie groß der Druck ist auf die Schweizer
Waffenindustrie die meisten Panzer hier
sollen in europäische Länder verkauft
werden aber die zögern denn weil die
Schweiz neutral ist darf hier gekauftes
Kriegsgerät nicht an die Ukraine
weitergereicht werden jetzt fürchtet man
ums Geschäft
es geht um die Existenzgrundlage ohne
Export kann die Schweizer
Rüstungsindustrie nicht existieren und
im Moment scheint der ganz Export
wegzubrechen
Deutschland wollte dringend benötigte
Schweizer Munition in die Ukraine
schicken Dänemark und Spanien Waffen
alle Anträge abgelehnt aber auf
internationalen Druck hin bahnt sich
jetzt eine Sensation an in einem Land
für das Neutralität zur Identität gehört
will plötzlich eine Mehrheit der
Menschen das neutralitätsrecht
Aufweichen die Schweizer im moralischen
Dilemma helfen oder raushalten wir sind
ja immer neutral geblieben für alle und
sollten es eigentlich auch so bleiben
aber Hilfe ist eigentlich gut und nötig
auf jeden Fall neutral bleiben ja
warum weil die Schweiz immer neutral
gewesen ist erste Zweite Weltkrieg
machte das Sinn heute
eher weniger oder auch eine Partei nach
der anderen wirft Prinzipien über Bord
sogar die rechtskonservative SVP
die neutrale Schweiz will der Ukraine
nicht direkt helfen aber sie sollte
nicht blockieren wenn andere helfen
wollen wir dürfen keine Waffen liefern
dabei soll es bleiben denn nur so sehen
wir neutral aber andere Länder unsere
Partner unsere westliche
Wertegemeinschaft daran zu hindern dass
sie Waffen aus ihren Beständen oder
Munition liefern dürfen das ist nicht
neutral das Parlament hat der Regierung
jetzt empfohlen die Wiederausfuhr von
Schweizer Waffen in Ausnahmefällen zu
erlauben Völkerrechtler finden Waffen
verkaufen und neutral sein wollen
funktioniert nicht das war jetzt muss
ich entscheiden
entweder sie trägt ein klein wenig zu
militärischen Unterstützung der Ukraine
Bewilligung und verletzt dabei das
neutralitätsrecht oder sie respektiert
das neutralitätsrecht und erscheint
dabei bis zu einem gewissen Grad als
moralisch unbeteiligt die Schweiz ist
unter Druck glaubt er weil man Vertrauen
verspielt hat als Wohlfühloase
frischer Olli geichen das sind natürlich
Gelder von autokarten klettokarten etc
die immer wieder in der Schweiz
auftauchen das sind die schwierigen
Beziehungen mit der EU und ich meine
schon da ist einige ungehaltenheit mit
dem Spiel die Regierung muss jetzt
abwägen was der Schweiz wichtiger ist
das über 100 Jahre alte
neutralitätsprinzip oder das europäische
miteinander gegen Russland
ja da läuft eine wichtige Diskussion bei
unseren Nachbarn im Süden hier bei uns
jetzt noch mal Johanna
bei der Deutschen Post droht eine
weitere größere Streikwelle denn auch in
der dritten Tarifrunde konnten sich die
Gewerkschaft Verdi und der Konzern nicht
einigen valeriehala im Frankfurt woran
sind die Verhandlungen genau gescheitert
und wie geht es jetzt weiter ja ganz
klar Angebote und Förderung lagen
offenbar zu weit voneinander der
entfernt die Post sagt sie sei an die
Grenzen des finanziell Machbaren
gegangen und die Gewerkschaft meint das
Angebot liegt weit unter ihrer Forderung
nun ruft sie ihre Mitglieder zur
Urabstimmung auf und damit drohen
Arbeitsniederlegungen die heftige
ausfallen könnten als die der
vergangenen Woche verdi fordert 15% mehr
Lohn für die Post Angestellten Laufzeit
ein Jahr und begründet ihre Forderung
vor allem mit der hohen Inflation die
Beschäftigten könnten sich keinen
Kaufkraftverlust leisten laut
Gewerkschaft bekommen 140.000 der Post
Mitarbeiter ein Monats Grundgehalt von
lediglich
218 bis 390 € brutto
Deutsche Post DHL ist hoch profitabel
den Löwenanteil ihrer Gewinne aber
erzielt sie eigenen Angaben zufolge im
Ausland in Deutschland macht der Post
vor allem das schrumpfende Briefgeschäft
zu schaffen die Gehaltsforderung der
Arbeitnehmervertreter hat sie deshalb
mehrfach als realitätsfern abgewiesen
Verdi jedoch hatte von Anfang an mit
Warnstreiks gedruck gemacht knapp
100.000 Beschäftigte hatten sich daran
beteiligt Millionen Briefe und Pakete
kamen nach Angaben der Post in Folge
dessen verzögert an nächste Woche soll
die Uhr Abstimmung starten und dann
könnten schon bald wieder die
Briefkästen leer sein vielen Dank
Valerie nach Frankfurt
wegen des vom Besten beschlossenen
preisdeckels für russisches Rohöl will
Moskau seine Ölförderung drosseln und
zwar ab März um 500.000 Barrel pro Tag
über eine weitere Kürzung soll er
abhängig von der Marktlage entschieden
werden
Ölpreise reagierten mit einem deutlichen
Plus
zum Wintersport da gab es heute bei der
Biathlon Weltmeister Weltmeisterschaft
in Oberhof eine erste Goldmedaille für
das deutsche Team und zwar im Sprint für
Denise hermannweg
es ist so eine Mischung aus hüpfen und
schweben Denise Herrmann Weg hinauf aufs
Podest ganz nach oben als Weltmeisterin
bei ihrer heimwm was soll man dazu noch
sagen mag was ich kaum zu träumen dass
sowas hier passieren kann also das kann
man sich schon fast nicht vorstellen und
dass du das heute erleben darf das ist
umso schöner der Druck am Start er ist
immens Denise Hermann Weg soll eine
Medaille holen nicht nur für sich
sondern für die gesamte Heimwehren die
am besten Falle zu einer Art Biathlon
Wintermärchen werden soll auf der
Strecke ist sie stark das ist klar aber
wird die Nies Hermann Weg dem Druck auch
am Schießstand standhalten liegend steht
die Null das ist gut und stehend steht
sie auch das ist noch besser Denise
Hermann Weg läuft nun wie entfesselt
stürmt dem Ziel entgegen und damit dem
Sieg was für ein toller Tag in der
Rennsteig Arena gibt's kein Halten mehr
und den Zug den hat Denise Hermann Wick
am Ende dann auch noch erwischt und das
obwohl dieser zu da zumindest
musikalisch keine Bremse hat
[Musik]
ein toller Tag beim Sport damit sagen
wir danke für Interesse heute und gerne
bis morgen und auf der Hinweis auf unser
heute journal Update gegen 0 Uhr 25 von
uns allen hier auch dem Team hinter den
Kameras ein angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend dieses kleine
Sturmtief hier über dem Mittelmeer hat
in den letzten Tagen in Sizilien für
Regenmengen von über 300 Liter pro
Quadratmeter und für einige Schnee
Überraschungen gesorgt jetzt heute Nacht
zieht das Tief allerdings südwärts und
damit kann man auf Sizilien so langsam
wieder aufatmen jetzt kommen wir aber zu
uns und da sorgt dieses kleine tief
Robert für viele Wolken morgen aber nur
vereinzelt etwas Regen dann setzt sich
schon wieder hoher Druck durch und hält
allen Regen von uns fern außerdem geht
es mit den Temperaturen etwas aufwärts
im Norden in der Nacht schon verbreitet
frostfrei im Süden aber wie der
Knackigkeit mit bis -10 Grad hier ist es
auch oft klar ab und an gibt es Nebel an
den Küsten gibt es einen frischen
Westwind mit stürmischen Bönen dazu aus
Norden eben diese Wolken aus denen immer
mal wieder Sprühregen oder schneekse
fallen kann das ist nicht viel es könnte
aber in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen vor
allem in den frühen Stunden für lokale
Glätte sorgen morgen gibt es weiter im
Norden und in der Mitte viele Wolken da
kann immer mal wieder etwas rausfallen
mit Mengen um die zwei Liter pro
Quadratmeter ist das aber kaum der Rede
wert wenn es in höheren Lagen nicht
gerade gefrierender Regen ist dazu im
Nordosten einen frischen starkbögen
Westwind ein ganz anderen Tag Wind
schwach und mit viel Sonne gibt es
zwischen dem Schwarzwald und dem
Berchtesgadener Land die höchsten
Temperaturen aber am Niederrhein mit um
11 Grad also richtig gehen mild am
kühlsten ist es in Ostbayern mit
Höchstwerten von nur 1 Grad und dann
setzt sich in den kommenden Tagen
Schritt für Schritt mehr die Sonne durch
es ist allerdings auch Nebel mit dabei
die Temperaturen steigen bis am Dienstag
auf 5 bis 14 Grad regen und Schnee sind
nicht in Sicht tschüss